I don't know if I'm comfortable with
playing who would you rather with
cartoon characters today we are playing
would you rather Disney Prince edition
concert awesome the thing is that a
there are no black Prince's so that's
the first issue
princes in the Frog no he wasn't black
she was black he was not who didn't love
Disney movies as a kid serial killers
would you rather get lost in Flynn
riders woods or get crazy or if that is
really fun or get cozy with Christos
frozen forest both sound dangerous what
that's like camping I don't want to do
either of those this just looks dumb
like he's like a big dumb jock I hate
stupid but like I thought Quinn has that
like flavor to him he would give you
some really good stressful dick and then
you be like yeah I wanna the blonde
which is surprises cuz I'm more of like
a tall dark and handsome kind of girl I
haven't seen either of these movies it's
the same movie I haven't seen this new
haven't seen frozen
also I'd like to get cozy in the woods I
love the idea but cuddle it up next to a
fireplace next you were strong and it'll
be huge let me say he hasn't been
touched in a while I don't long time
they both look like they don't season
their chicken oh no now you could not a
flake of see somebody visions never
pepper that's why see to us which one
Kristof yeah Chris Flynn I guess I can't
deal with the other ones had I was able
in would you rather be rescued by
Hercules as mussels or Prince Florian's
kiss is that how you say his name
that was the prince and Snow White he's
boring plain like cardboard
you know he's bad in bed Hercules 100
the thing is is that I don't even know
if anyone knows who plays for I don't
know what plays Florence came from he
I've never seen him before my seeming
Snow White
it's not what yes he looks just like her
too also he just kissed this random
sleeping chick because when she sleeps
no more kissing sleeping women that's
weird here's a thing Hercules didn't he
technically like take steroids the story
had her Achilles get his muscles he was
a god oh he was a God who wouldn't want
a [ __ ] god Hercules any day I would
love him to just pick me up can we just
talk about Hercules and what's-her-face
they're a good hot couple they were a
hug she's hot too I'm going Hercules who
wouldn't want to be quite a guy at least
whines I bet you that be some trippy ash
he could do all these sort of magical
fiddly dudes to your dumb that's the
thing is that he could lift me up and
throw me places do it in a swamp with
Prince Naveen or do it on a horse with
whose Fobus Phoebus thank God Brown
here's something he's brown for sure but
no what is his ethnicity who's Phoebus
no I don't know what fetus is from every
smile yeah he doesn't do terribly also
has like a chinstrap he does have a guy
to wear like a tank top
drink beer all day he won't have a job
he'll change her oil though I'm going
Prince Naveen
are you joking my ass look at that smile
what his eyebrows look at style truth
novena seems like again another
stressful dick like you would be so mad
at him cuz he's lying he's like scheming
he's got other girls he just seems like
he'll be a bare selfish lover but then
he would just like dip you down I'd go
with prison
pretty easy if I had it my way I would
do it on a horse
with prints and a beam so mix the two
yeah cuz I like the horse I don't want
to do it in swamp but I don't like that
dude but I like the swamp could be fun
it's like free long messy that's enough
vide free loom I think we're both saying
yeah either easily oh oh now we're going
through animals would you rather make
out with llama Cusco or frog Naveen
here's the thing
both are illegal to do just so you know
of course but first whatever you had
failed gonna animal is it creepy that it
was easier for me to pick between these
two yes wait pause it is easy for you to
choose bestiality didn't several hot men
before this yeah I feel like llama Cusco
wouldn't be good at making out he's
still pretty selfish those lips though
no I know you look sad there but he's
still pretty he didn't learn how to be
giving yet and a frog Naveen just looks
like a charmer I could just turn the
pants off yeah yeah I think Cusco will
be fun because he would get me close to
crunk crunk also awakened my inner gay
as a child cuz there was something about
he was just big and dumb and that's sort
of my tight just like big dumb and full
look I think I'm gonna go with Cusco
though cuz at least you have a something
humour and I like the guy that can make
me laugh if you can make a girl laugh
and you make her do anything I think
David Spade probably means cute because
yeah they say you have to kiss a couple
of frogs to get a prince so for that I
would kiss him no who's going away oh my
god where milo is at my lure Milo Milo
Milla Milo that like a pair of glasses
or handle Prince Philip's sword that's
sort of a euphemism for dick isn't it
he's pretty cute but he's like your
all-american he's a trump supporter oh I
don't know he could be a Bernie
supporter because I feel like he's he
dresses better than the other one you
know what he's like someone whose
parents voted for Trump and he's like
trying to select be rebellious
he'll be the type to date a black guy or
a black girl just because he live and
what select stick it to his parents
Milo on the other hand if I kiss cute I
thought you could go on teat of
interesting hikes with him yeah I'm Milo
100% who is he from again meelo here's
the thing if he gonna let me sleep after
we've talked about this on the podcast
sleep sex is great I can't believe we've
talked about this before when you just
wake up and like you're having sex
consensually with someone ah ah it's the
best feeling it's like but you're
dreaming then all of a sudden you're
coming I'm going with Prince Philip I
have not experienced that so I'm gonna
go with Milo thatch because I think he
looks like a guy this study is he looks
like a hipster can most fearless guy
that you would show be into that does
stand-up that's a little weird and
probably skateboards you love that guy
leave me alone get wild with Tarzan or
get fancy with Prince Charming oh dang
this is an easy choice
I feel like Tarzan would have to be some
fun because he wouldn't have a way to
communicate with you so it would just be
wrong crazy think about like he's only
watch gorillas hook for his entire life
but good one was tall said throw me up a
vine toss on my [ __ ] hair roll around
in the dirt feed me a banana oh my god
Tarzan fancy boys they they're too
prissy they've had everything done for
them ever like I mean would just be like
hmm this is good for you rich Tommy
would never go down on you Prince
Charming is missionary only his
accessories are turf you're never doing
anything
holy missionary cars on 100% I mean I
feel like Tarzan and look at those pecs
he bursts out the only thing is that I'm
sure like he doesn't made so I'm like
there's probably a lot of smells like
that sex would have to smell disgusting
would you rather climb Lee Shang's pole
or get wet with Prince Eric this one
honestly is very very hard but I love
both of these oh this is a tough one
yeah baby wow this is the first one that
I'm gonna have to say I'm gonna go with
both I would let them tag team the [ __ ]
out of me oh my god I would I'm not
choosing
Prince Eric why I always sort of really
liked Prince Eric wait you know he's a
prayer
she's had everything handed to him this
guy has a hard labor under his sleeves
well he's not wearing anything you know
are you sure it's Jesus Christ look at
those biceps oh this is tough
Prince Eric a hundred percents a very
very CUTE they didn't have like blue
eyes yeah Harry that's and I don't know
but he's in a fish so I'm gonna say Lee
Chan cuz he also was like a brooding
time I mean their mom like right there
can I pick both yeah not at the same
time I think I'm at the same code I
don't want them at the same time not yet
at least
maybe in a couple years but to rather
marry the Beast and live in his castle
he wants her back into a human
Oh or marry Aladdin and live on the
streets
he will never become a rich who looks or
money what's more important to you
Aladdin yeah because I'm like a matte
beast is very large and that's like I
personally like hair but that might be a
bit much I would go with Aladdin I don't
want to say I'm into beasts yeah he was
much hotter as beasts when he turned
back into the Prince it was like oh girl
he just would be nice and warm and fuzzy
probably cuddled good and you could
scratch your back I think it would like
to cuddle with the Beast that would be
so fun
also the mansion is nice and then you
have all those servants does the Beast
even have a good point
Aladdin I think Aladdin I still pickle a
tin because I actually really liked his
little place worried that he has and it
overlooks the castle it looks really
pretty and to eat your own one jump
ahead of the blop blip right you am dad
did a lot of dude bow help Prince Adam
out of his wet clothes or bird Prince
Edward's puffy sleeves in a fire what I
don't like him Prince ever Edwards I
would burn his leaves in a fire is that
what happens in the movie they look hook
up and then his outfit catches on fire
I don't understand this question I'm
going prints whatever beast writes Adam
I still you know I still like his name
is Adam you know that's funny
the beasts name a little funny beast
outside a beast form Prince Adam and his
wet clothes that chest though what the
hair he looks like Jessica Chastain's
wow I guess I would help Prince add him
out of his wet clothes because he would
catch a cold I think I would go with
Prince Adam but I don't think I would
stay long I would just help him out of
his wet clothes I think I would do
Prince Adam like after a heavy night of
drinking when like everything's blurry
and you just like it's been like months
and it's just like you know at this
point anything I think we learned a lot
about each other today yeah Ryan wants
to sleep with the Beast and he wants to
have sex in a swamp in a swamp and I
also learned that Fernando just wants to
get really drunk and have sex with the
Beast as well so like at least I'm
upfront about it you have to get drunk
fast yeah that's where the problem is I
realized I didn't know there were so
many Disney princes I didn't actually
know about because I was too focused on
the ladies weren't we all Disney princes
I've liked the old ones are not as hot
as anyone's none of them were hot I'd
rather have sex with like mr. incredible
a saint right what I guess I should
watch frozen yeah holy fish that's what
we learned in this video how have you
made it this long
Missy I don't know we gotta go cuz we
got to go watch frozen do you want to
build us no you can't see if you don't
know the origin story